au h de Paris puisque nous avons pris
cet exemple c'est par tonne que des
trains de wagonnet enlève chaque jour le
rebut de la
[Musique]
nuit nos ancêtres mangeent plus que nous
mais nous mangeons mieux la production
augmente la consommation suit le niveau
de vie s'en trouve amélioré gourmandise
et publicité font le reste le ventre des
villes est insatiable produire c'est
consommer on ne croit plus aux
marchandises inusables les objets
fabriqués doivent être vendus puis jetés
pour faire place à d'autres objets
fabriqués à un rythme toujours plus vif
ainsi l'argent circule la production
s'écoule les affaires vont bien chaque
année les besoins des cités en matière
d'approvisionnement deviennent plus
grands le restaurant tourne à l'usine
les halles dévorent rue pr rue tout un
quartier toujours plus de bouches à
nourrir d'appartements à meubler
d'armoires à garnir mais
après après et bien il y a cela
l'entassement près des villes des
déchets de la table du ménage des
maisons désormais sans cave ni grenier
250 kg par an et par personne d'ordure
ménagère 330 kg prévus pour
[Musique]
1975 les déchets qu'est-ce que c'est
qu'un déchet c'est aussi bien l'ordure
ménagère que le débris métallique que la
bouteille de plastique que l'on jette
que l'on jette où jusqu'à présent
c'était un problème individuel et
familial on le rejetait de l'autre côté
du mur chez le voisin qui lui-même
l'envoyer chez le voisin et quand tout
allait bien on arrivit peut-être un de
ces sesmillants dépôts d'ordure
municipal dont vous verrez tout à
l'heure quelques images mais maintenant
il n'est plus possible de se
désintéresser d'un tel problème la
civilisation contemporaine comporte une
telle consommation de produits et
d'objets que ce problème est devenu un
problème d'ordre public de santé
publique un problème d'aménagement du
territoire
oui au bout de la production intensive
il y a le rebut triste et inquiétant
spectacle que celui des hall une fois le
marché fini tant de cageau de fruits
abîmés de Funes de légumes d'emballages
de toutes sortes on en vient à craindre
de voir la ville toutes les villes
ensevelisent un jour sous les
répugnantes montagnes de leurs
excrétions le mince pinceau des
balayères semble peu de choses pour en
venir à
[Musique]
bout pourtant le problème de
l'enlèvement des déchets de ménage est
l'un des plus anciens dont des mieux
résolus au halall de Paris puisque nous
avons pris cet exemple c'est par tonne
que des trains de vagonnet enlèvent
chaque jour le rebut de la nuit il en
restera rien au bout d'une heure ou deux
le grand flux des déchets fera place
nette pour la marée des produits
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
comestibles
[Musique]
nettoiement
arrosage Paris n'aura pas la peste cette
année ailleurs dans les villes moins
armées dans les villages dépourvus de
tout àégû la lutte contre le rebut est
moins sévère moins parfaite combien de
tadimmondic sous les pains parasol du
Midi combien de cassers sous le ciel du
Nord dès que le soleil sera haut les
poubelles redeviendront vides et la rue
net de leur présence rester net tout
court cela est notre affaire à tous ne
haussons pas les épaules devant ces
affiches qui collé sur un mur crasseux
nous engage à garder notre ville propre
après tout on sait désormais nettoyer
les
[Musique]
murs tout finira dans ces camions qui
collectent brois et emporte les déchets
mais les emportent où chez quel voisin
irons-nous les jeter les voisins sont
trop près il n'y a plus de désert en puu
entire il faut détruire les ordures
Paris parvient à 100 % mieux la capitale
tire de cette destruction un profit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
matériel les détritus d'une grande ville
POS les mêmes problèmes d'ailleurs que
les détrituses des petites collectivités
des campagnes je dirais même qu'à la
campagne ça pose d'autres problèmes en
particulier dans le Midi où les feux de
forêt sont souvent suscités par la
combustion naturelle des tat d'ordure
consence c'est un problème général ce
problème général consiste à détruire ses
hordure et à mettre fin à ces dépôts
contrôlés ou non contrôlés que l'on voit
à peu près partout lorsqu'on circule sur
les routes de France par conséqu il faut
détruire ces ordures et il y a deux
moyens de les détruire le premier c'est
par le feu l'incinération des ordures
ménagères on les brûle soit sans espoir
d'en tirer un produit quelconque c'est
l'incinération pure et simple la
destruction d'un produit
désagréable mais évidemment la
déperdition aussi d'une matière première
car il faut bien considérer que le
déchet est une matière première qui
sommeille le deuxième procédé
d'incinération c'est incinérer les
ordure pour en tirer une matière
première qui est l'énergie l'énergie
calorifique cela pose évidemment des
problèmes d'investissement extrêmement
coûteux car il faut
transformer ces flammes en chaleur et
envoyer ça soit pour chauffer les foyers
soit pour alimenter les usine c'est donc
une solution qui n'est envisageable que
dans les très grandes cités et à ma
connaissance il n'y a qu'à Paris
maintenant ten que l'on transforme les
ordures pour en faire le chauffage
[Musique]
urbain certains penseront au vieux mythe
moral de la purification par le feu
d'autres remarqueront tout simplement
que c'est une solution parfaite et
radicale l'hiver cette société
parisienne de chauffage urbain envoie de
la chaleur dans une foule d'immeubles
public et privés combustible gratuit
l'été l'énergie que dégage la combustion
est utilisée pour fournir du courant à
l'électricité de France quand il fut
question il y a longtemps de réutiliser
les déchets domestiques un humoriste
proposait d'en faire du savon ou du
beurre aurait-il imaginé qu'on en ferait
un jour de la chaleur et de la
lumière le deuxième procédé c'est
transformer les ordures pour en faire un
produit en vue de l'agriculture en
quelque sorte c'est c'est de retourner
aux sources puisque la plupart des
ordures proviennent et nous le voyons
ici au marché mouar de produits de la
terre et Essie de renvoyer ces ordures
sous forme d'engrais organique et le
problème alors est de transformer les
ordures de tel sorte qu'elle soit
consommable qu'elle soit vendable aux
paysans mais là le problème est un
problème d'éducation car il faut
instruire les agriculteurs de la
possibilité de la richesse que
contiennent encore ces ardures une fois
qu'elles sont transformées en
[Musique]
humid